Good evening everyone and welcome. I want to thank you for coming. For all of you who don't know me
and Dr. Kelly Walderman, I'm a staff clinician here at Connors Clinic. My background is pretty
eclectic. I have a medical degree and I've practiced family medicine. I also have a naturopathic medical
degree. I have certification in neurofeedback and in functional neurology and I also earned certification
in genetics from the Nutri-Genetic Research Institute this fall. I want to give you a little bit
of background or why I'm passionate about genetics and that starts about five years ago when I was
sitting realizing that you know I married my husband and we were living in Kansas City and we had two
children in Kansas City and we moved back up to Minnesota about 2010 and at that point I realized that
we had a really big problem on our hands. It's that I was living with three Kansas City chief
stands and I was the lone Viking stand and you know the Viking stand it's just very lonely and you
need a lot of support so I've my husband my son Jack my daughter Bella and I was supportive and I was
okay with them being chief stands and being the only Viking stand until this happened. It started
hurting for the Green Bay Packers. I could not take this anymore but I had to take things into my own
hands and I decided we had to have another baby so at that time the MTHFR gene was becoming really
really popular and we know that the MTHFR gene is important for making a methyl folate and methylation
secondary to only phosphorylation is important in genetic expression and detoxification and also in
neural transmitter synthesis. So I knew if we were going to have a healthy baby that I had to optimize
this pathway and my two older children actually have problems with midline defects and I knew that my
daughter had lip tie and tongue tie my older son had a and actually has a gluteal club dimple which
by the grace of God closed and prevented him from having spina bifida so I knew that the MTHFR gene
was probably something that I needed to get tested for. I was working here at the Connor's clinic
Dr. Connor's night test to be sure enough I had the MTHFR gene I had that sniff that single nucleotide
polymorphism and we did testing to make sure that before we had this third baby the spikings fan
that I was optimized and sure enough we got our spikings fan and he's perfect and so that kind of
sparked this genetic optimizations looking at these pathways and getting really excited about it
and it was something that we were looking at and practicing it was really important for what we were
doing because these conditions are definitely affected by genetics. So one thing led to the next
and we continued to study genetics and I ended up at a Bob Miller seminar. Bob Miller is the founder
of RetroGenetic Research Institute because he's also the founder president of the NEPL genetic nutrition
analysis software. I was able to go to the seminar this fall and start learning about his program and
started running these genetic reports on Monday when I got home from his training. This completely
changed my practice and the results that I was seeing were really specific because when you hit the
nail on the head you can get better results and I have a letter from a patient a little boy to his
mother about the kind of results that you can get using this when you're really specific and this
is our own Thanksgiving time so we've been running the software for about two months. Dear mom,
my teacher gave it some assignment to write a letter to some of you who are very thankful for
so I picked you mom. Sometimes school is hard for me except for gym class because they make me sit all day
long and I just want to run outside and play. Mom's school has been so much easier for me lately so mom
I just want to say thank you because you make my life better. I hope when I grow up I can help people
like you how we love Jeff. So that was my time. We were able to find patterns and genetic defects
in that report that we had not been able to find for years looking at that. We were able to optimize
his genetics. We couldn't change him into a Minnesota twins fan but at least we were able to help him
with his anxiety, irritability and ADHD symptoms and this is where genetics is going. This is where
the future of medicine is going is that we're able to look at these patterns and able to help people
very specifically and this is in our practice like people are learning more and more about genetics
on their own. They're learning tests. They want practitioners are knocking at the door or saying help
me interpret this data. But what do we do with practitioners? There's 600,000 pieces of data that we're
looking at. It's can be really confusing. I know that when I was trying to optimize my son I was
doing everything I could but just didn't have the tool to put it together. So if Bob calls it
if they get 3D tests being played underwater in its complexity. Fortunately three companies have
come together to help us make this really easy as practitioners. The first is nutritional specialty
company. They formulate the specially formulated professional health products brand of methyl genetic
nutrition. The second company is the Nutrigenetic Research Institute. So this is the institute that looks
at these genetic variants and compares them with conditions and they also have a certification
program that you can do online. And then the third is the methyl genetic software. So methyl genetic
nutritional analysis. So that's the software where you take genetic data and plug it in and you get
these beautiful reports. Twilight has one that she'll be passing around just kind of give you an idea.
This company also takes in the labs and symptoms surveys so that you're able to generate a really
nice report. Here Newtie just a brief snippet on him. He's a president of professional health
products. He's been in the business for 40 years. The vice president of professional products is here
at Heatherboard and this company has just been on. Their formulation are really, really good and you
see just extremely, really good results with them. And they're just committed to these cutting edge
formulation. It was Pete who was behind helping Bob bring these specific methyl genetic nutrition
into their hands. And there's a picture of Bob. Bob Miller's 23 years practicing natural path.
He is a founder of president of both companies, the Nutrigenetic Research Institute and the
methyl genetic nutrition analysis. This is Bob practicing, especially Bob presenting at iLabs
and it will be presented in November on his work that won a research award for the study of
Lyme disease and genetic. And let's talk a little bit about what that Nutrigenetic Institute does
when we're talking about doing studies. So we're looking at conditions for specific genetics. So Bob
focused on Lyme disease and there was some studies done. Phase one was done in Helsinki, Finland in
2016. There he presented the correlations between Lyme disease and high amounts of HFU genes.
Those genes are responsible for iron metabolism and also gad genes and those responsible for
conversion of glutamate to GABA. Phase two was done in Philadelphia later that year 2016 and that was
where Bob showed correlations between high amounts of glutamate genes and dopamine genes and also in the
Lyme disease community. And then phase three was the iron that was done in Paris. It was the iron
variance in the Lyme community as well as Nerf two and that's the master anti-accident
pathway as well as M-tore. We'll talk a little bit about that. But it's showing that inflammation is
really a big piece of what's going on in these chronic disease states. And then phase four we just
talked about was that eyelets involve what a researcher before there for his work and they're looking
at the pathways of that Nerf two and you're also looking at a topology in M-tore and how it relates
to these chronic disease of Lyme disease and we'll talk about those pathways. So they're doing lots of
groundbreaking research. And about seven years ago, so about some practicing for 23 years, seven years
ago, the M-tachyphar started eating popularity and people started treating with methyl folate. They
tried to just treat the SNP so we know that doesn't work. And Bob saw in his practice when people tested
for having the M-tachyphar that giving methyl folate sometimes was great. It got really good results.
Sometimes it didn't get good results. It got anxious and they got more inflamed and so Bob created a
pyramid approach because we know we have to treat the stuff by step. And so this is what Bob teaches
at his seminar. This is what you can learn in the certification program is that at the top of the
pyramid is the M-tachyphar. So we don't necessarily want to treat that first. You just start at the bottom
and the bottom of the pyramid has to do a lot with inflammation. And so looking at these pathways
and I'm not going to go into a lot of this but Bob covers his body and leave it below. We'll cover
this and you'll feel very confident what you need this seminar or if you're doing the online training
to start at the bottom and work your way up. So for instance, if we're trying to give someone
methyl folate and they still have a histamine problem and they have a glutamate problem, they're not
going to do very well. So with my son, we were giving him methyl folate and he was anxiety was
getting worse because he still had a glutamate problem. So it really puts it in a very specific
order that's easy to follow as a practitioner. I remember when I showed up at the Chicago seminar
for Bob Miller and he had this slide up and I thought to myself, I mean I really love high level
I hope he had a stream and I looked at it and thought, oh my. But I'm going to give you the 30,000
foot view of this and let you know how it's important in all kinds of different chronic diseases
is that the amtor, so right in the middle there, stands for a million target of rep or my son
and amtor is responsible for metabolism in cell growth. Okay, so when let's get activated,
we're pushing into cell growth. Atop the G so atop the G now know that we're right there. That
means cellular cleanup. So there are two different processes that are really supposed to be in a nice
balance to prevent a lot of disease. So when atop the G is activated, we're cleaning up cellular
debris, we're helping clear out the molds, viruses, toxins, it's really important. Actually want to
research or want to Nobel Pride in 2016 for his work on atop the G so we know that it's really gaining
grown or how important it is. But the problem is that when we're activating amtor that we're actually
suppressing atop the G so you have too much cell growth and then you're actually suppressing
that cleanup and Bob showed in his research that a lot of the chronic Lyme disease have genetic
defects in atop the G so they can't cellular clean and then on top of that all kinds of
epigenetic things, we'll kind of look through these as a video about our over driving amtor.
Okay so you have two things to line on. We're looking at the plastics so there was a study done
that 90% of the water in the United States is contaminated with fluid plastics and that's driving
amtor that pathway. Having protein drinks and dairy too much of that if you're a muscle
filled we're buying over that's good if you want to drive amtor but if you have cancer that's really
not where you where you want to be is driving that. EMF, high protein source corn syrup, iron and
rest foods even methyl folate will drive that pathway. So we're out of balance that's what we're
looking at out of balance and then we're doing the studies that show yep sure enough. So they have
the products by methyl genetic nutrition that can help and then you're also you're being a functional
medicine doctor you're helping correct these lifestyle interventions as well and so you're coming
into better balance and now that'll be taught in the seminars that will be taught in the online
education as well but just to give you an idea of what we're trying to do here is balance those pathways
out and then which is really the neatest part of this is that Bob is created with Pete with the
professional health brain company and it's created products that help drive these pathways into
correct the balance so a topology assist has in it known compound known extracts and things
which is for green tumor that help to balance that out. So you're looking at your patient you're
trying to work on decreasing their exposure pesticides decreasing the amount of EMF all those other
things and then a topology can just help balance them out so how do we learn all this there's a lot
but it is it is learnable if we have webinars so Bob is always continuing to update us and he has
webinars every Thursday at 7 p.m. and also they're recorded so you can just plan back in the car and
listen to what the latest research is and I give copies of the slides to anyone if they want to go
to and sign up for those and then we hold live classes for about a time for you and that was like
the Chicago class up I went to try and learn all of us. The next live class is coming in really soon to
February 16th through the 18th and the next at the views. There I was presenting on day one in the
morning a very basic overview of genetics. What are these pathways and what does it mean with
co-factors? So you can walk in knowing really nothing about genetics per se other than what you've
learned in school with the basic level get that refresher and then dive into these pathways in the
pyramid approach and then Bob and Emily get literally taking over and getting through all the
good information and then additional classes so we're going to be in Florida and May and August
will be in Pittsburgh and October will be in Austin. The online certification course so I did this
as well. This will get you a certification to be a nutritional genetic consultant. The first three
modules of this are three so it's a trial you can go in and start listening to these modules seeing
if it's something that you want to perhaps implement in to your practice and then if you choose to
complete it there's 14 modules the balance is 405 it's really reasonable and it's really good education
so let's talk about the actual software okay the method genetic nutrition analysis and that's
that report that we're passing around. So the method genetic nutrition analysis what you do is you
have your patient get their raw data we used to use 23 of me but now Bob came up with his own it's
called the origin only resource it's a custom kit you'll order that your patient will cheek
swallow cheek and send it back in the data will be sent to you to be able to load it so it really
cuts down on you can do this from distance you'll send the patient the online survey so you'll send
them the questionnaire that couples with with the the data and then you'll enter any lab that you
can that you have you want to run labs from do that later too it's going to show you compare since
it's not just looking at it saying okay what are we going to treat because we're going to treat these
genetic defects it's looking at a bigger picture and looking at as a functional medicine provider
how you can be really specific. So looking at the reports we're going to look at all the different
genes are going to be listed and then you're going to have numbers one or two and so we get a copy
of the gene one from mom one from dad and the number one means that you have only one variant for that
gene so two would be two variants of the gene and then you're looking at the supplement recommendation
based on the number of SNPs and then you also can add in symptoms and labs and that'll give you
a supporting of between one and 10 so you as a practitioner you know what your patient is
presenting with and then you can go through and decide if that's actually a problem for them you
get commentary so you can learn as you're running these reports and also you can flip through them and
just look for the colors of red yellow and orange and those will mean that the person has us to
statistically significant variation from the wild type from a normal population that that gene is
not working properly that gene is is a variant so we look at the colors again so we're looking at the
mean distribution so everyone of those genes has this bulk hurt and you can show your client you can
have your patient look at this and see how far they are off on it and then you can make the clinical
decision in that particular gene is or is not working and if it needs to be supported
we'll also get a supplement recommendation page on built into the software and then it'll give you
again this is a supplement this is how strong the rating is and it'll tell you if it's something
that they should probably permanently be on optional temporary so that line and then how's
trying the recommendation is and then how the symptoms correlate in so it really is a
it brings it all together which is really nice and then it'll give you warnings and
in contraindications too it'll have flags and it'll give you more education about check for this check
for this so if it's something that you're doing and it's new so it's warnings those countries when
you see that flag it's something you're going to want to pull up it just read through it and it'll
teach you as you go as well and you can generate your supplement report and it happens to be
tree of life which is fog millers and have it on there customize it for your patient
what's new this month is the interactive pyramid so putting in that raw data putting in the symptoms
putting in the labs the interactive pyramid just gonna start to move will actually flag for you
what it thinks are the issues are for your patient and so it'll say step one generally
say to start with so we look at all these okay there's something going on this means symptoms
so you can further explore like what what is going on with that patient as far as conditions
then you can scroll down and look at the genes if you want to and look at the distribution so it's
really interactive and you could you could just use the pyramid to update things as well you put in
a new symptom survey and continue to run through the data to see if it's changing so you for
being here you can get a free trial for the report so you can take your genetic file and plug it
in and get yourself a report with a pyramid and see if it's something that you want to want to use
every report thereafter that you sign up to have the subscription it's $20 per month and $25
so it's extremely affordable and you're welcome to charge whatever you want to run that report
and to also do the interpretation for it and the reports are updated to add no charge
which is really nice and this is an important slide for your contact information so how do you get
started looking at the genetic analysis that the website looking at who can I call for help
the next steps we have all that on there we also have the certification program and then the
professional health products the nutritional specialties they have their phone number on their
tube if you have any questions for them and it started all their products are really good
we don't just use the mental genetics we also use a lot of just the professional health products
in the office and they're extremely good products so that concludes that so we're going to talk about
anti-aging kit a little bit too but if we have so let's see how I do with this
hello I'm not a burst genetics doctor I'm older but with PHP they're working to create kits so
that it makes it so it's easier for people to figure out what they need to do so this is an anti-aging kit
it comes with a excel sheet where you can plug in certain data about an individual and it'll tell
you exactly how to dose this out for that particular person so it comes with four products
and the nice thing about this is this is not dose like every single day so feel like what you do
things are a certain time of day certain days of the week and so it's rotated but it's individualized
for each person based on questions so you don't have to run a DNA test on them to do this kit.
That was a question so that'd be for like doctors who are doing DNA test or something like that.
Yeah so this is a great way to start so these are easy to get people familiar with how to not
necessarily just do things every single day like they think you want to take an official everyday
this is actually going to help them specifically with what's going on with them and their personal data
so any questions about software are they getting started how much are the tests
that is to be determined I believe it's going to be somewhere around 1 to 70 equal to 80
somewhere below 200 so it's really affordable the turnaround time will be passed
so like two weeks versus six so you want to do this what are the first steps
so the first step would be I would I would download your own data do your own data file
data or do you have anybody's where I work just take a look at what's the first step.
Yeah I would find or we could send you a sample and start with and then get on the certification
it's free the first three modules start your plan about it start to see if that's something that
you'd want to implement in like I said I went to that summer in Chicago and I was doing
it on Monday I was literally in the airport running these data files through because it's
so easy to implement it really is some really great job about how do you feel so you know so for me
and I wrote a gym and we do we do a functional nutrition like you say a lot a lot of our clients
they for them they always come to us because they want to get in the car right you will have a
bike in who's like five percent like that he wants to get in and we'll have like a 75 year old lady
who wants to get in the car right so everybody always wants to leave out but really for us that's
just a piece of equipment they get healthier so there's um so it's not just about you know body
composition you know a lot it's about formats but it's also about help so I do feel like this would fit
in our context. I think if you're perfectly there's the fatty acid metabolism comes to mind
optimize you know everyone's a little bit different and how they um can take in different
forms of nutrition and so for me I I want a product called fatty acid cyst because my body's not
very good at actually creating that pathway or doing that pathway so it would be it would give it
another edge to what you're doing already a specific edge and say look right here you're not doing
this great well let's try this and I'll move forward with it especially with the top of the G
and think it up so it's really really everybody's because all those factors we're just living in
this mTOR driven so we do a lot of mTORs you do a lot of mTORs yeah my father has multiple of my
own which I know is that a pathway that you want to drive harder so definitely tell me about that
so we want to balance it out we don't enhance our patients we definitely don't want to drive
them toward all you guys okay yeah you don't want to drive them toward you definitely want to make
sure that they're a top of G it's a really nice balance and cut down on all those epigenetic factors
that drive that mTOR pathway and figure out what's the cause of it and get rid of that as well so how do
you know your balance so you could do a lot of work that's a really good yeah so we're trying
to balance so how do we measure balance so we would we'll specifically for cancer patients we
would measure we do a lot of different testing just to measure like all they're doing there's
that new cancer test to see like what their cancer is doing this is score we could also just look
at overall symptoms picture we could do it you're an organics and just see if everything's balanced
there's just a couple it just kind of like depends on what we're treating but overall that's a
that's a really good question of how do you know when you're in you're in if you plug in the
L-cat test into that right now I believe you can only plug in you're an organics testing and I think
by word and they're like in my garden trend at this point but you're so you're gonna expect yourself
yeah you'll be able to plug in and do that one too so you really don't have to plug those in
all the data's affected sure you'll go oh okay that makes sense with that and I know you know just
because it's not pluggable doesn't mean it's not something that it's really utilized
well like cholesterol counts I don't think it has cholesterol if you look at that report it
it has a risk but um plugging in that would just be kind of going all lucky or risk out here and then
this is you know you know how do we support that and that's what's cool because it'll be the
supplements will be right on there and then you can use your judgment should we try this let's try
it and see you look if you can order cholesterol how many companies are there are people like
Bob Miller who are doing the analysis do you know how many companies there's love
under I think that's five or under and have they ever gotten together and seen with reports have
the same with the same yeah I don't think that's the same yeah right right and I know that was
that was an issue too is that interpretation of the SNPs and interpretation sometimes it's
backwards like genetic geney some of when they're reading it it was actually backwards and they were
not at worst when they were so comparing them I don't what I've seen it's not apples
it's kind of like space rates who got their first yes but who got their first I think seeking help
Ben Lynch was probably the first person people who said hey mthfr is a big deal and then
just kind of figure from there would you say Bob Miller took it to the next level Bob Miller
have to look at this go we can't jump in he's doing this the genetics with the conditions with
the specifics on that like he won't be one research or words from eyelets looking at that and that's
just the agility expert he's doing autism now and all kinds of other disease processes
so if I could tell it to your question are there other companies that are doing these analysis
taking the 23 and V data and putting it into software just as a practitioner I've had patients come
that have done well all the other ones that I know of but I get it there's probably about five
major ones and it's I thought it interesting they all took the same data from 23 and V
same amount of steps and the the readout that they gave which is basically their software
only compared it such a small number of steps to be significant so my patients got to be in
and they're like oh I already got the readout from genetic duty or whatever I don't want to slam
any other ones but here's the readout like they looked at 30 steps that's like taking a you know
a look at a drop of water in the ocean and say here's the constitute of the water and it's like
you got to think a bigger picture of this so look at this report here and it's it this is in
it but see this is the 423rd update on this software it's being updated almost on a weekly basis as
do step data is discovered because this research is coming out literally on a weekly basis because
so much money is ported to this research right now right because it's the hot thing so you know
if you're not gathering it oh there's new information what the CACG means oh let's put it in
the report so the report is getting longer and longer and longer and which means the benefit
of the patient is getting better and better and better but it does mean that the practitioner has
to stay up on this stuff too on a weekly basis but the more information that you could gather from
from the data that's collected from from on 23 and B and now if you're going to be so much better
with the new test because there's 900 thousand steps that are going to be measured is you can get
a bigger picture for the patient so that's what we tore we did the steps from before we had 23
weeks it's like use you just kick it up big enough picture it's really see what's going on
well it's not also true that 23 and B doesn't even have the amount of like they drop sniff they
haven't added a reason they've eliminated right but I mean if they have people I still have
version 4 of 23 and B that they did prior to September last year there's still tons of data that
could be gathered off of that that you could get a really good readout but again you have to have
the software that's going to to convert that data into usable information as for the practitioner
and you know if you're not if you're skipping 90% of the genes that 23 as we have read it just
ignoring them because we don't know what they need then I need to find somebody else who knows what
some of those need so we can use that data for the patient's best interest at least that's what I
felt that it could be Bob's software is constantly learning how to never stop it never saddest
how long have you been doing? So I just started using Bob's software in September and just
saw the results just totally and Dr. Conner said we would use that for a while
I think to the other part of it and this is just the piece that I have to add is really with the
Newtriidentic Institute and the MGN line that professional health products has
when you say our other people doing it yes or our other people doing the genetic part of it but then
you're going to all of these different companies and you're trying to pull what the right products
would be and when the partnership actually became with Pete Newty and Bob Miller in the information that
is constantly being read because the smarter the more people that are taking the test the smarter
that the software actually gets which is amazing but the biggest part of it is that there's
products that were specifically developed based off of what is showing up and they're reporting
on that knowledge over and over so there's a lot of collaboration so truly it's the only thing
that's out there right now that has and I'm not saying you know there's other products that can be
utilized with the information that you get from the report but there's a whole entire product
having developed and you know specifically around the research that's being done and the testing
so that's that's the biggest gap for all the other companies that are out there is that they
might be doing your research and they might be able to read what the results are but they don't have
any products supporting them so that's the largest gap we had you know Bob Miller has outgrown 23
means so that was also the biggest because of the exactly what Dr. Connor said is that you know we
had to go elsewhere and there was another company out there that was willing to take him there
in his research there which is really exciting because you're absolutely right he is not he is not
ever satisfied with you know enough is enough he knows that there's more and he he literally stays
awake at night to make sure that he's not only fighting that for his clients and his patients but he's
fighting that for everyone else out there as well and he's changing lives I mean the the people that
that I've heard the seminars that we've had he's literally changing lives I mean mothers are bringing
their sons and daughters and family members and they've never felt better he's literally turning people
around with you know with nutrition and you know things that are all safe and not with the end days
you know from pharmaceuticals so it's really exciting which leads it right into the title of
presentation in the future and I think as a person in my particular role you know I see a lot
of people or they have so much they're paying out a pocket you know they're deductibles and stuff
and it's time for education on you're going to pay for it out of pocket why not pay for something
that's preventative versus reactant